well we can talk now to the shadow
leveling up secretary at least and Andy
who was in Wigan today thank you for
being with us this morning well the
drama of the conservative leadership
contest has really been about Boris
Johnson hasn't it Willie won't you run
is he flying back from holiday in the
Caribbean telling colleagues he's up for
it you know are we all back within the
Boris Johnson soap opera
I mean the drama is just incredible the
only thing it's not been about is the
country and meanwhile you've got people
whose mortgage payments have gone up by
more than 500 pounds on average a month
you've got people paying a very very
heavy price for this ongoing chaos
inventory party and whether it's Boris
Johnson Rishi sunac or any of the other
contenders who've been floating around
this weekend essentially what the Tory
party is about to do is bring the
arsonists in to try and put out the fire
that they started it's just not good
enough we need not just to change a
prime minister we need a change of
government
um someone in your party though would
say that Boris Johnson is actually the
greatest threat to labor I just want to
have a look you know this is Angela
Reyna on LBC in July Boris had this
Teflon coating it's like a little magic
where he was able to get through to the
public Boris had so much going for him
he got an 80 seat majority and the
country was really behind him Here's
Lucy Powell and in-house magazine Boris
in his Heyday was a very formidable
campaigner who was able to reach parts
of the country that other conservatives
hadn't and wouldn't be able to reach do
you agree with your colleagues
well he undeniably won a big majority at
the last election and then very very
quickly the wheels came off the wagon I
wouldn't trust Boris Johnson to run a
bass let alone run the country he
degraded under based our politics he
lost all of that Goodwill from the
country and from his own colleagues in a
very short space of time it's
extraordinary watching Tory MPS who put
in letters of no confidence in him just
a few weeks ago saying he wasn't fit to
hold the highest office now talking
openly about trying to bring him back
it's a sign of absolute utter
desperation in the Tory party it's time
that the public were brought back into
this conversation because there is a
clear choice between a Tory party that
have crashed the economy and presided
over 12 years of chaos bringing our
National Health Service to its knees and
soaring crime rates and a labor party
that could bring calm and stability back
to the markets be careful and sensible
with every single penny that we spend
because it's people's money and they
haven't got a lot of it
you know you obviously want a general
election that is very clear but you know
with your sort of public responsibility
hat on you know you're talking there
about how difficult things are for
people we do use stability it's been a
difficult couple of months to say the
very very least who do you hope becomes
the next prime minister next week
well kirst armor it's the obvious answer
because if we had her but he's not going
to be the next prime minister next week
is here
well but the truth is it makes
absolutely no difference at all who the
Tory party choose because even before
they crashed the economy and left
working people paying the price we'd had
12 years of low growth and the highest
tax burden on working people in 70 years
they haven't got a clue how to set this
right because they're the people who
created this problem in the first place
we've got to get good jobs back into
every community in this country and get
the economy firing on all cylinders
again we could become a world leader in
clean energy there are a million good
jobs on the road to Net Zero and we will
invest to bring them here you just heard
Jim O'Neill saying there's a strong case
for investment to rebuild the fabric of
this country from the ground up that is
what is at stake for the for this
country we've got a clear choice to make
and that's why we're arguing for a
general election not because there's a
lot at stake for the labor party but
because there's so much at stake for the
country
um you say that you know it wouldn't
make any difference to the next
conservative prime minister is I mean
that's not really true is it like I get
that you really want kissed armor in
there I get your frustrations that you
know there's another at least a contest
going on without a general election but
obviously it would make a difference who
wins the contest wouldn't it for the
country
I don't think so when you've got a
government that is completely out of
energy and out of ideas whoever becomes
leader of the conservative party in the
next week or so is going to inherit the
same problem it's not just that they've
crashed the economy and now they've got
to find money from somewhere whether
it's raising taxes on working people or
um cutting Public Services as Jeremy
Hunt has been floating it's not just
that they've got a very divided Tory
party it's that they've got the same
tired failed ideology that got us into
this mess in the first place the idea
that you can grow the economy by
investing in a small handful of people
in a small number of sectors in one
small corner of the country and the
benefits of that will trickle down to
the rest of us it just demonstrably has
not worked we say that every person and
every place has a contribution tonight
to the future of this country and that's
why we're going to invest to bring those
good jobs to Britain get money back into
people's pockets and get the economy
growing again
okay um well let's have a look at
Labor's economic plan then shall we you
know your sort of positioning yourselves
as the party of a fiscal responsibility
we know that there is a physical
tightening on its way uh really whoever
wins uh but certainly if Rishi zunak
does the spending review no longer
applies departments have been asked to
find efficiency savings would labor
spend more money on public services than
the conservatives
well we've already set out plans to get
money into the National Health Service
by scrapping non-dom tax status which we
think will raise about three billion
pounds and spending roughly half of that
on getting more Health visitors more
training more doctors and nurses into
the NHS because we Face a crisis this
winter we've got more than a million
people on waiting lists and we've got to
do something to act now but we're what
we're really interested in is how you
can reform Public Services you know
Jeremy Hunt who's currently the
chancellor is the person who failed to
invest in the National Health Service
didn't bring it up to speed with
digitalization so that we're doing we're
spending more to do less that's why
we've said we'll prioritize when we do
borrow we're not going to borrow for
day-to-day spending we're not going to
live out with our means but we are going
to prioritize getting investment into
the economy so that we can get Public
Services working far more efficiently
and help to people who need it at the
moment moment they need it not waiting
until people hit crisis point before we
intervene Which is far more costly and
so so damaging
so is that yes then you would spend more
money on public services than the
conservatives
well well we're not we're not going to
borrow to fund day-to-day spending it's
the consequences of doing that when you
haven't costed it and you don't know how
you're going to pay for it are very
severe we've just seen that they
literally crashed the economy with a
multi-billion pound package that they
couldn't cost they couldn't fund and
ultimately all that help that was
promised those energy help with energy
bills they just couldn't deliver when we
make promises we intend to keep them and
that's why every single thing that we
propose between now and the next general
election will be fully costed fully
funded and will publish an assessment in
government of the impact that that will
have on the wider economy as well okay
because obviously you know if everything
is going to be fully costed if you
aren't going to be borrowing to fund
day-to-day spending we all know there's
a big black hole in the public finances
around 40 billion pounds that's even
after Jeremy Hunt reversed the mini
budget it was around 60 billion before
that according to the IFS would you put
up taxes in order to try and plug that
black hole
well we've already said that we would
expand the windfall tax on the big
energy producers in order to get more
money back into people's pockets and off
their energy bill sure but this is this
is the point isn't it I'm not I'm not
sorry that we're going to be careful
with people's money because it is their
money and they haven't got a lot of it
and the last thing that this country
needs is more Reckless spending when the
government has has just crashed the
economy by saying that they'll Target
tax cuts to the richest and then
couldn't work out how they were going to
pay for it of course we'll invest in our
Public Services we saved we've built the
National Health Service we created
comprehensive education in this country
and in 1997 after years of the Tories
degrading our Public Services we came in
and rebuilt them From the Ashes of the
Thatcher era of course we'll prioritize
that and that's why we said that we
would scrap non-dom status and get money
into the NHS it said that we would end
the Arcane system where you've got
police forces up and down the country
all procuring their own Services
separately which wastes a huge amount of
money and will bring those things
together in order to get more police
onto the streets through the savings
that we make there but we're going to
think creatively and smartly about how
we spend every precious Penny and we're
going to prioritize rebuilding this
country the fabric of this country from
the ground up okay
um just finally you want an election how
are you going to get one are you going
to call a vape
it's entirely up to Tory MPS now the
tragic fact is that the future of this
country lies in the hands of a small
number of people who are currently
putting party before country we're
calling on them to put country before
party and do the right thing they know
that Britain can't go on like this
everybody in this country knows that
Britain can't go on like this and it is
unconscionable that we're going to bring
back one of the old tired failed leaders
from the past in order to put out the
fire that they started we all know it's
not going to work Tori MPS know in the
heart of hearts it's not going to work
and it is time for a general election
okay thank you very much indeed Lisa and
Andy there are talking to us from Wigan
today